ja willkommen zu aktuellen Sitzung heute
geht es um die Theorie der Aufklärung
bei David jung und bei Hegel das sind
zwar zwei historisch verschiedene Denker
aber wir können Sie im Rahmen dieses
Seminars philosophische Themen der
Aufklärung in ein sehr enges Verhältnis
bringen wenn es um die Probleme geht mit
denen sich diese zwei Philosophen
befasst haben erstmals
einen kurzen Schrift verfasst mit dem
Titel über Aberglaube und Schwärmerei
das ist deswegen zentral für unsere
Seminar Thema weil die Aufklärung
traditionellerweise begrifflich als eine
Gegnerin verstanden wird die gegen den
Aberglaube gerichtet ist und Jung
thematisiert jetzt zwei Phänomene der
Unmündigkeit so könnte man das mit
kanzbegriffen nennen nämlich aber glaube
und schwer mal rein wir wollen jetzt in
dieser Sitzung schauen wie ich um diese
Formen der unbedingt Arbeit versteht und
worin ihre Gründe entdeckt die Ursachen
warum wir dazu neigen er hat hier diese
zwei Phänomene genannt und er nennt sie
Entartungen der wahren Religionen sind
also Formen von Religion die nicht dem
Sinne der Aufklärung entsprechend das
heißt dass es durchaus auch wahre Formen
von Religionen geben kann jung richtet
sich in diesem Text nicht grundsätzlich
gegen alle Religionen das heißt
Aufklärung muss nicht immer als
Gegenbegriff zur Religion verstanden
werden sondern nur als Gegenbegriff zu
einer falschen einer unechten Form von
Religion und unechte Form von Religionen
sind nach jung eben aber glaube und
schwererei er sieht jetzt die Ursachen
für diese Formen der religiösen
Unmündigkeit in unerklärlichen
Ängsten und Befürchtungen den der
menschliche Geist ausgesetzt ist das
gemeinsam mit die Gründe die menschliche
Fantasie erdichtet sich fantasieobjekte
und hier unten ist eine Bestimmung des
Aberglaubens im Sinne von Schwachheit
Furcht Schwermut verbunden mit
Unwissenheit das sind die wahren Quellen
des Aberglaubens weiter sagt jung dass
unsere fantasieflüge Unternehmen also
man stellt sich die Fantasie häufig
bildlich vor wie ein Vogel der im
Fantasie Reich fliegt das ist der
Spielraum für die
Einbildung unserer Seele eine
Geisterwelt also in der unechten
Religion in der
abergläubischen vielleicht auch
schwärmerischen Religion auf den Begriff
der Schwärmerei kommen wir noch zu
sprechen da
überschreitet unsere
Einbildungskraft ihre Grenzen
ihre Geisteskräfte
er kommt auch hier auf die Schwärmerei
zu sprechen und die
Ursachen dafür sind wie er sagt Hoffnung
stolz Vermessenheit eine lebhafte
Einbildungskraft verbunden mit
Unwissenheit das sind für ihn die Gründe
für die Schwärmerei die natürlich auch
mit waren Gebilden zu tun haben und hier
wird es problematisch insofern als
wärmerei häufig auch unsere Grenzen der
Moral nicht nur unsere Geisteskräfte
auch die der Moral
überschreiten und er spricht von einem
wahnsinnigen Sperma also eine
Radikalisierung vielleicht auch eine
Form von Fanatismus wie man heutzutage
schwerer Reihe bestimmen könnte
ja dann bringt er noch ein interessantes
Zitat nämlich eines dass ich gegen die
priesterrichte die Priester sind jetzt
nicht nur irgendwelche religiöse
Funktionäre sondern es ist eine Instanz
die sozusagen die Macht der Unmündigkeit
verkörpert das ist eine
Subjektivität die Interesse daran hat
dass Menschen unmündig sind also
schwärmerisch werden oder eben
abergläubisch werden
das ist interessant weil darauf wird
auch Regel dann zu sprechen kommen der
aber glaube ist auf Angst Leid und
Niedergeschlagenheit gegründet als es
eine Reaktion darauf auf diese
psychischen Verfasstheit der Menschen
und hier unten sagt er je stärker die
Beimischung des Aberglaubens ist desto
größter ist das Ansehen der
Priesterschaft also die Priesterschaft
als macht die ist interessiert daran die
kann nur dadurch existieren dass die
Menschen abergläubig
ängstlich und niedergeschlagen sind so
viel zu David you wir haben ihn gewählt
weil er eine interessanten Bezugspunkt
auch für Georg Wilhelm Friedrich Hegel
den denke der klassischen deutschen
Philosophie darstellt hegel hat in
seiner Phänomenologie aus des Geistes
aus dem Jahr 187 sich auch mit der
Aufklärung befasst im Kontrast zum
Aberglauben wir werden das uns jetzt mal
gemeinsam anschauen sie die Aufklärung
weiß den Glauben als dass ihr da
Vernunft und Wahrheit entgegengesetzte
wie im allgemeinen Gewebe von
Aberglauben Vorurteilen und irrt wie man
ist so organisiert sich ihr weiter das
Bewusstsein dieses Inhalts als ein
reiches Irrtums also Aufklärung ist das
vernünftige auf der Seite der Wahrheit
dem entgegen steht der Aberglaube als
rechtes Irrtums Vorurteilen
dann steht natürlich da noch ein
Hintergrund dahinter es gibt ein
Hintergrund der eine böse Absicht hat
und die abergläubischen betört also
praktisch ihre Sinne verwirrt
betören kommt von dem Wort Tor
also man ist nicht ganz recht bei
Vernunft im Aberglauben das ist
praktisch der Kontrast zur Aufklärung
und wer ist jetzt dahinter da haben wir
wieder ein Bezug zu der Beziehung
spricht nämlich vom betrug einer
Priesterschaft die die Masse der
abergläubigen Menschen manipuliert und
auch letztendlich beherrscht hier
spricht der von disputismus
ja jetzt ist es aber so dass die
Aufklärung in einer sehr problematischen
mit Hegel gesprochen dialektischen an
dialektischen Verhältnis zum Aberglauben
steht das heißt Aufklärung Aberglauben
sind nicht so zu verstehen dass es bloß
Gegenbegriffe sind sondern die
Aufklärung ist dadurch problematisch
dass sie sich nur von dem Aberglauben
ihrem Gegenteil abgrenzt sie macht sich
nämlich dadurch abhängig
und dadurch wird sie gerade zu bedroht
in ihrer eigentlichen Aufgabe
sagt die Aufklärung verwickelt sich in
einen Widerspruch dass sie sich in
Streit eines etwas anderes zu bekämpfen
meint
das heißt die Aufklärung die hat sich
noch nicht ganz begrifflich
emanzipiert von ihrem Gegenteil sie ist
noch eine Abhängigkeit dadurch dass sie
den Aberglauben bekämpft macht sie sich
abhängig dadurch
es besteht hier eine Bewegung die
Momente zu entwickeln und sie in sich
zurückzunehmen also wir müssen genauer
betrachten wie das begriffliche
Verhältnis von Aufklärung und
Aberglauben zu verstehen ist
er spricht von einem Kampf der aber der
Aufklärung mit dem Irrtümern und ein
Kampf ist natürlich jemand Abhängigkeit
Verhältnisse und jetzt
kritisiert er das die Aufklärung in
ihrer Abhängigkeit ihrer kämpferischen
Abhängigkeit vom Aberglauben dass sie da
ist noch sich selbst aufklären muss sie
verhält sich nämlich
zunächst rein negativ gegen Glauben
insofern sie ihren Inhalt aus ihrer
Reinheit ausschließt und ihn für das
Negative ihres selbst nimmt also sie
bezieht ihren Inhalt nur im Kampf gegen
den aber glauben und ist dadurch nur
negativ bestimmt auf der muss aber
positiv gestimmt werden als etwas was
nicht nur gegen etwas kämpft und was
auch darüber hinaus mehr zu bieten haben
das heißt mit anderen Worten die
Aufklärung muss sich erst über sich
selbst aufklären begrifflich nämlich
nicht nur eine negative Einstellung zu
haben gegen die Irrtümer gegen den
Aberglauben gegen den Buddhismus der
Priesterschaft sondern als etwas
eigenständig autonomes das nicht von der
Gegenaufklärung sozusagen abhängig ist
ein kritischer Begriff der Aufklärung
man könnte Hegel auf den Begriff bringen
Aufklärung der Aufklärung über sich
selbst im begrifflicher Hinsicht in der
nächsten Folge werden wir eine
interessante modernere Theorie der
Aufklärung kennenlernen die stärker
gesellschaftstheoretisch orientiert ist
die aber nichtsdestotrotz an Hegel
anknüpft es geht um Max Horkheimer und
Theodor Adornos Schrift die Elektriker
Aufklärung die erstmaligen 1944 im
US-amerikanischen Exil erschien und dann
unser Team 40 in Amsterdam in einer
größeren Auflage der Untertitel lautet
philosophische Fragmente hier auf diesem
Bild sieht man beide denken und rechts
hinten im Hintergrund ist Jürgen
habermaß damals so jung den wir in der
darauffolgenden Sitzung dann anhand
seiner Theorie des kommunikativen
Handelns als ein Denker der Aufklärung
noch näher betrachten werden dann
bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit bis
zur nächsten Folge auf filmcast